der Verwaltungsrat hat folgendes
beschlossen erstens wir werden die
nettokäufe von Vermögenswerten im Rahmen
des Pandemie notkaufprogramms mit einem
Gesamtvolumen von 1.800 Milliarden Euro
mindestens bis Ende März 2022 und so
lange fortsetzen bis der Verwaltungsrat
zu dem Schluss kommt dass die
Krisenphase des Coronavirus vorüber ist
guten Morgen die Europäische Zentralbank
hat die Erwartungen der Ökonomen
bestätigt und hat ihre Pandemie not
Anleihen um 500 Milliarden Euro
aufgestockt nach meiner Rechnung erhöht
sich das auf insgesamt 1,85 Millionen
die Geschwindigkeit als auch das Ausmaß
der Käufe sind absolut historisch dies
ist Diagramm zeigt was seit dem ersten
März passiert ist in den letzten drei
Wochen gab es einen beispiellosen
Anstieg
was hat sich bei der Fett getan es gibt
ein 1,9 Billionen Dollar
Entlastungspaket das vom Kongress
beschlossen wurde die demok
ratenion Dollar schweren
Haushaltsbeschluss veröffentlicht könnte
man alles was die Fett in der
vergangenen Woche getan hat als Flutung
des Systems mit Geld bezeichnen ja auf
jeden Fall und die Möglichkeiten sind
unbegrenzt es gibt hier keine Grenze
oder ein Limit das System wurde einfach
mit Geld geflutet
ja das ist richtig so kann man das sehen
wo kommt es her wurde es einfach
gedruckt
wir drucken es digital wir als
Zentralbank haben die Möglichkeit Geld
digital zu erschaffen das tun wir indem
wir Schuldscheine für Anleihen oder
andere staatlich garantierte Wertpapiere
kaufen das erhöht die Geldmenge
wir glauben dass die Inflationszahlen
die wir jetzt in 2021 sehen steigen
werden
ich kenne keinen Zeitpunkt in der
Vergangenheit wo Geld und Finanzpolitik
der Art von den wirtschaftlichen
Rahmenbedingungen abgewichen sind
im letzten Frühjahr haben wir in sechs
Wochen mehr anleinkäufe getätigt als in
den gesamten neun Jahren von 2009 bis
sollten wir jemals wieder eine
inflationäre Stimmung beobachten wie
beispielsweise in den 70er Jahren und
sollte der Einzelhandel sehr nervös auf
diese Stimmung reagieren dann könnte
dies die Inflation neben steigenden
Rohstoffpreisen oder auch einfach die
Annahme darüber problemlos diesen Effekt
verdoppeln oder verdreifachen
sowohl die Zinsen als auch die Aktien
sind überbewertet wenn man beides
kombiniert sind sie extrem überbewertet
sie sind auf dem höchsten Stand seit 100
Jahren ich bin ratlos
ich habe Angst davor dass Demokratien
auf die Idee kommen durch Geld drucken
all ihre Probleme lösen zu können
vor uns ich weiß dass das Scheitern wird
wenn man zu viel druckt landet man in
der gleichen Situation wie Venezuela
das ist simple Mathematik die
fiatwährung ist jetzt der Störfaktor der
das Wachstum des Zählers also der
globalen Gesamtverschuldung gegenüber
dem Nenner also den globalen
Bruttoinlandsprodukt auflöst
wir haben einen Punkt erreicht an dem es
kein Zurück mehr gibt der Zähler wächst
und übersteigt das Wachstum des Nenners
in jedem denkbaren Szenario was bedeutet
dass man Geld drucken muss um diese
Schuldenspirale zu bewältigen
[Musik]
wir alle haben schon etwas von
Wirtschaftszyklen gehört und davon dass
es Dach moderner Wirtschaftstheorie
vollkommen normal ist dass Darstellung
Wachstum und starke Expansion eine
Wirtschaftskrise folgt Alter as burns
ehemaliger Berater des Präsidenten der
Vereinigten Staaten und Wesley See Mitte
amerikanischer
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler beschreiben
1946 diese geschäftszyklen als eine Art
von Fluktuation
ein Zyklus besteht aus Expansionen die
in vielen Wirtschaftszweigen etwa zur
gleichen zeitauftreten gefolgt von
ähnlich gelagerten Rezensionen dieser
Abfolge von Veränderungen ist
wiederkehrend aber nicht periodisch vor
dem 20 Jahrhundert wurden Finanzkrisen
auch durch externe Ereignisse ausgelöst
eine der bekanntesten sind Kriege
es gab nur eine einzige Finanzkrise die
nicht auf externe Ereignisse
zurückzuführen war die Panik von 1825
bei der etwa 70 Banken aufgrund
riskanter Investitionen bankrottlingen
und zwar aufgrund eines Mannes Dragon
McGregor der große Investitionen in die
Kolonisierung eines Landes getätigt
hatte dass es gar nicht gab
wenn wir uns die Geschichte ansehen
stellen wir fest dass dieser Zyklus vor
etwa 100 Jahren begann
ein wichtiger Faktor war der Ausstieg
aller großen Nationen im Jahr 1940 aus
dem Goldstandard dieser repräsentiert
das gesamte Geld das eine Zentralbank
besitzt kontrolliert oder produziert
nur aufgrund dieser Goldmenge basiert
der Goldpreis
daher ist die verfügbare Geldmenge
relativ zum Gold das gehalten wird
dieser Ausstieg legte den Grundstein zur
Finanzierung des ersten und sogar des
Zweiten Weltkrieges die Regierungen
erkannten schnell dass sie nach Ausstieg
aus dem Goldstandard so viel Geld
drucken konnten wie sie benötigten
aber auch häufig der Grund für den
Untergang von Regierungen oder
Königreichen das römische Reich ist ein
gutes Beispiel
dropping
[Musik]
1940 war das Vereinigte Königreich eines
der ersten Länder welches den
Goldstandard aufgab das war der Moment
in dem wir anfingen diese kurz- und
langfristigen Zyklen zu sehen vor allem
die kurzfristigen
mehr als 100 Jahre nach dem Ausstieg aus
dem Goldstandard ist es eine allgemein
anerkannte Tatsache dass unsere
Wirtschaft enzyklen funktioniert die auf
einer Inflationsphase und eine
anschließenden deflationsphase basieren
schon die Tatsache dass dies erst vor
100 Jahren begann zeigt dass unser
Geldsystem Mängel aufweist dies ist auch
der Grund für das unvergleichliche
Wachstum dass wir speziell im 20
Jahrhundert hatten
diese Inflation ist auf unsere
Abhängigkeit von Schulden und Krediten
zurückzuführen nach der modernen
Geldtheorie ist die Verschuldung der
Motor des Wirtschaftswachstums und nicht
die Produktivität
Ray dalio erklärt in seinem Video sehr
gut wie diese wirtschaftsmaschine
funktioniert mit der Zeit lernen wir
immer weiter dazu und dieses
angesammelte Wissen erhöht unseren
Lebensstandard wir nennen diesen
effektproduktivitätswachstum fleißige
Unternehmer steigern ihre Produktivität
und ihren Lebensstandard schneller als
jemand der bequem und träge ist aber das
gilt nicht unbedingt auf kurze Sicht
langfristig ist das Produktivität
kurzfristig ist jedoch der Konsum am
wichtigsten Grund hierfür ist dass das
Produktivitätswachstum nur wenig
schwankt und somit kein großer
Impulsgeber für wirtschaftliche
Fluktuation ist es sind Kredite da sie
es uns möglich machen mehr zu
konsumieren als zu produzieren und sie
sind es auch die uns zwingen weniger zu
konsumieren als zu produzieren wenn wir
sie zurückzahlen müssen
sie Artikel der langfristige
schuldenzyklus und der Aufstieg von
Bitcoin steht sind nicht Produktivität
sondern der Grad der Verschuldung bei
volatilen wirtschaftlichen Schwankungen
hier die hauptantriebskräfte
aber zurück zu den Zyklen Ray dalio
beschreibt den schuldenzyklus und wie
dieser sich auf die Produktivität
bezieht
der die Verschuldung schwankt in zwei
großen Zyklen der eine dauert etwa 5 bis
8 Jahre der andere ungefähr 75 bis 100
Jahre die meisten Menschen spüren zwar
die Schwankungen sehen Sie in der Regel
aber nicht als Zyklen an da sie sie Tag
für Tag miterleben
der kurzfristige verschuldungszyklus
lässt sich anhand des Verhältnisses von
Schulden zu Einkommen und den von der
Zentralbank festgelegten sind setzen
beobachten ja die Zentralbank liegt die
Regeln fest die ist unserer Wirtschaft
erlauben sich unangemessen zu
verschulden und entscheidet später wann
sie zusammenbrechen kann das ist der
sogenannte boom-ent-zyklus die jüngsten
Beispiele sind die globale Finanzkrise
von 2008 und die dort kommen Blase in
den Tausendern der langfristige
schuldenzyklus setzt sich aus mehreren
kurzfristigen Zyklen zusammen zwar geht
es mit unser er Wirtschaft in jedem
dieser Zyklen auf und ab doch auf lange
Sicht bringt erwachstum und mit jedem
Zyklus hilft unsere Wirtschaft weiter
Schulden an weil wir lieber Kredite
aufnehmen als Schulden zurückzuzahlen
irgendwann kommt der Zeitpunkt an dem
mehr Schulden als Einkommen zu zahlen
sind historisch gesehen ist dies der
Zeitpunkt an dem sich der langfristige
schuldenzyklus verschiebt die Menschen
aufhören Geld auszugeben und anfangen
ihre Schulden zurückzuzahlen
es kommt zu Rezessionen einer Erhöhung
der staatlichen Unterstützung eine
Abwertung der Währung sozialen Unruhen
und so weiter ist der Zeitpunkt erreicht
an dem unsere Wirtschaft ausreichend
entschuldigt ist beginnt die Wirtschaft
wieder zu wachsen
die Zentralbanken folgen hier drei
Strategien erstens Senkung der Zinssätze
die Zentralbanken liegen sowohl die
Zinssätze als auch die Spielregeln fest
senkt diese die Zinsen wird Geld leihen
billiger und die Menschen werden eher
dazu neigen dies zu tun das führt zu
einer Spirale in der immer mehr Geld
geliehen werden muss weil das der
leichtere weg ist
und wenn man sich die Zahlen anschaut
wird dies von Zentralbanken auf der
ganzen Welt seit Jahren praktiziert es
ist gerade Zustande sich am US-Dollar zu
orientieren wenn die US-Zentralbank die
Zinsen senkt dann werden auch alle
anderen ihre Zinsen senken
dies erhöht den Wert des Vermögens und
erleichtert die Aufnahme von Krediten
heute sind diese Zinssätze in den
wichtigsten Volkswirtschaften bereits
drastisch gesunken und in vielen sogar
negativ geworden wenn die Zinssätze auf
Null fallen gibt es keinen logischen
finanziellen Anreiz mehr Geld zu
verleihen das kann eine Zeit lang so
weitergehen bis es nicht mehr geht
zweitens es gibt die quantitative
Lockerung auch Geld drucken genannt
wovon dieser Mann hier spricht es
erlaubt der Zentralbank schultitel und
Finanzanlagen zu kaufen das bringt
Bargeld in die Hände der Investoren
hilft aber nicht den Bürgern es lässt
die Preise von Vermögenswerten in die
Höhe schießen was in der Regel zu einer
Inflation führt dies lässt die Schere
zwischen Arm und Reich größer werden da
Ersparnisse an Wert verlieren
Immobilien und Rohstoffe gewinnen gerade
massiv an Wert
drittens die Erhöhung der Sozialausgaben
oder andere Instrumente wie zum Beispiel
Konjunkturpakete
is will sollte es irgendeine Art von
Krise geben werden die Leute mit
Eigenheimen keine Möglichkeit haben Ihre
Immobilie oder ihre Investitionen
andersweitig zu schützen weil sie
einfach nicht das wissen die Fähigkeiten
oder die Instrumente haben um das zu tun
sie sind also diejenigen die am meisten
verlieren werden
Investmentbanken wissen was auf sie
zukommt sie wissen sie haben eine
Strategie und Sie werden sich aus der
Affäre ziehen
aber dadurch entsteht eine Kluft
zwischen Arm und Reich denn das
zusätzlich gedruckte Geld landet ja
nicht in den Taschen der Verbraucher es
wird ein Banken oder an Investoren
ausgezahlt
das verschafft Ihnen einen weiteren Deal
es bringt Ihnen noch mehr Geld ein um
wiederum in viele verschiedene
Vermögenswerte zu investieren sei es an
der Börse oder in Gold
people don't have these options
ärmere Menschen haben diese
Möglichkeiten nicht das Geld erreicht
sie nicht was bedeutet das während
andere Leute reicher werden sie ärmer
werden weil ihre Ersparnisse auf der
Bank durch das Geld drucken an Wert
verlieren
Regierungen müssen also ihre Bürger
zusätzlich unterstützen denn man will ja
nicht dass ärmere schlechter gestellt
werden nur weil man selbst zu Elite
gehört die finanziell besser gestellt
ist
diesen Menschen muss direkt geholfen
werden indem man sie direkt finanziert
wie auch immer das aussehen mag
dir
finance
is und wenn man sich die Sozialausgaben
seit der Krise von 1929 anschaut also
der ersten großen Finanzkrise nach der
Abschaffung des Goldstandards sind diese
enorm gewachsen wie etwa in Frankreich
wo ca 30% des Bruttoinlandsproduktes für
Sozialausgaben aufgewendet werden es hat
eines der besten Gesundheitssysteme aber
auch die Arbeitslosenunterstützung ist
großartig verschiedene
Konjunkturprogramme helfen bei der
Finanzierung von Wohnungen etc
nötig wenn man diese Probleme nicht
selbst erschaffen hätte
in letzter Zeit haben sich die
Sozialausgaben aufgrund der koved-krise
erhöht so dass wir nur vermuten können
dass das Diagramm jetzt eher so aussieht
die Geldmenge ist die Gesamtmenge einer
Währung die derzeit in der Wirtschaft
verfügbar ist je mehr die Regierung
neues Geld schafft desto mehr steigt das
Angebot
dieses Geldangebot steht in direktem
Zusammenhang mit der Abwertung unserer
Währungen
viele Stellen diese Diagramme gerne in
versa um diese Entwertung zu zeigen denn
je mehr Geld produziert wird desto
weniger ist es knapp und verliert so
immer mehr an Wert
wir alle wissen das Geld damals einen
anderen Wert hatte ich habe Bilder
gesehen wie z.B dieses McDonald's Menü
aus dem Jahr 1972 auf dem ein Big Mac
nur 65 Cent kostet
die Zunahme der Geldmenge ist der Grund
für diese Entwicklung allein im Jahr
2020 hat die Geldmenge einen großen
Sprung gemacht es wurde viel Geld
gedruckt um die kurve-krise zu
finanzieren
in den USA haben wir seit Anfang 2020
einen Anstieg von über 30% der im Umlauf
befindlichen Dollar erlebt
auch wenn sich dies nicht sofort in der
Wirtschaft bemerkbar macht werden die
langfristigen Auswirkungen für den
sozial schwächeren Teil der Bevölkerung
spürbar
das hat langfristig sehr weitreichende
Folgen
nehmen wir zum Beispiel den
Technologiesektor hier sollten die
Preise sinken weil effizienter und
einfacher produziert werden kann doch
aufgrund der Inflation sinken die Preise
nicht was die Entwicklung neuer
Technologien wesentlich erschwert
die Regierungen nutzen Krisen darunter
den Klimawandel als Vorwand und
Billionen zu drucken auf lange Sicht
kann Geld drucken zu negativen
Ergebnissen führen da diese neue
Geldmenge die Entwicklung wichtiger
Technologien behindern kann die uns beim
Übergang zu erneuerbaren Energien helfen
könnten
Zentralbanken werden allerdings solche
Botschaften vermeiden so soll verhindert
werden dass sich eine Panik auf den
Finanzmärkten ausbreitet die zu großen
backgrounds führen können ein Land nimmt
das Vertrauen in die Währung verloren
geht rutscht unweigerlich in eine
Rezession und wird Jahrzehnte brauchen
um sich davon zu erholen
stattdessen verwenden die Zentralbanken
den Verbraucherpreisindex auch CPI
genannt er ist nur ein schwacher
Indikator dennoch einer der am weitesten
verbreiteten Indikatoren zur Messung von
Inflation und ihre Auswirkung auf die
Preise des CPI folgt dem Preis eines
Warenkorbs von Produkten die von den
Menschen konsumiert werden zumindest
sollte ein solcher Indikator so
funktionieren der Verbraucherpreisindex
weist jedoch in dieser Eigenschaft
Mängel auf er wird auf der Grundlage
dessen ausgewählt was die Menschen zu
kaufen bereit sind jedes Jahr werden
also neue Produkte in den Warenkorb
aufgenommen während andere gestrichen
werden
die Kaufentscheidung hängt jedoch vom
Preis des Produkts ab wenn aber die
Inflation steigt werden die Menschen
ihren Warenkorb ändern und den
Preisanstieg auszugleichen
dies macht ihn im Wesentlichen zu einem
neuen Warenkorb der CPI wird also nicht
den Preis des vorherigen Warenkorbs
sondern dem des neuen Warenkorbs Folgen
nachdem die VerbraucherInnen auf die
Preiserhöhung reagiert haben
safe den MS veranschaulich dies sehr gut
anhand des Fiat Standards stellen wir
uns vor wir verdienen 10 Dollar am Tag
und geben alles für ein leckeres Steak
aus das uns alle Nährstoffe liefert die
wir für den Tag brauchen
in diesem einfachen Warenkorb beträgt
der CPI 10 Dollar
stellen wir uns nun vor dass eines Tages
eine Hyperinflation über die Wirtschaft
hereinbricht und der Preis für unser
Steak auf 100 Dollar steigt während
unser Tageslohn bei 10 Dollar bleibt was
passiert dann mit dem Preis des
Warenkorbs er kann sich nicht
verzehnfachen weil wir uns das 100
Dollar Steak nicht leisten können
stattdessen begnügen wir uns mit einem
Fleischersatz Burger für 10 $, der CPI
zeigt auf magische Weise 0% Inflation
denken wir daran dass Regierungen und
nie die wahren Inflationszahlen nennen
werden sie werden sie auch nicht auf die
Zunahme der Geldmenge zurückführen weil
sie diese selbst verwalten das würde
eine Wiederwahl sehr problematisch
machen
nun haben wir so viel über Schulden
gesprochen das ist an der Zeit ist auch
diese Zahlen zu betrachten wir können
den starken Anstieg der weltweiten
Verschuldung sogar in den letzten Jahren
sehen um den Zusammenhang zu
verdeutlichen hier der Anteil der
Schulden am weltweiten BIP
356 Prozent wir haben 3,5 mal mehr
Schulden als tatsächlichen Wert diese
Schuldenblase könnte gestoppt oder
zumindest verlangsamt werden wenn die
Zentralbanken die Zinssätze anheben
würden was die Kreditaufnahme verteuern
würde das würde dem gesamten System eine
Verschnaufpause verschaffen
wahrscheinlich zu spät die
US-Zentralbank Fett hat dies 2018
versucht weil sie glaubte dass sich die
Wirtschaft von der globalen Finanzkrise
2007 erholt hätte
zehn Jahre sind nun seit der Finanzkrise
vergangen
ein schmerzhafter Abschnitt unserer
Geschichte der vielen Amerikanern ihren
Arbeitsplatz ihr zu Hause und auch ihre
Hoffnungen und Träume kostete wir haben
nicht nur die Zinssätze niedrig gehalten
um den Aufschwung zu unterstützen
sondern auch viele Schritte unternommen
um das Finanzsystem sicherer zu machen
ich bin zuversichtlich dass das System
heute stärker und in einer viel besseren
Position ist um Haushalte und
Unternehmen zu schützen
sie beschlossen die Zinssätze zu erhöhen
daraufhin ist der gesamte Markt
innerhalb weniger Wochen eingebrochen
der nasdag und der SP 500 vielen in nur
wenigen Wochen um über 20 Prozent
die Märkte haben einfach nur auf diese
Maßnahmen der Zentralbank reagiert
sich wieder auf die Tiefstände des Tages
zu alle 30 do-werte liegen jetzt im
Minus und die Dauer Jahresgewinne sind
verschwunden der S&P 500 ist in die
Korrektur gefallen das ist ein Rückgang
von 10% oder mehr gegen den jüngsten
Höchstständen alle Sektoren und das ist
das Wichtigste liegen derzeit im Minus
der nasdack ist auf ein
sieben-monats-tief Gefallen sehen Sie
sich den ziehen in business fearing read
Index an man will gar nicht hinschauen
er misst die Volatilität das Momentum
und die Nachfrage nach sicheren Häfen er
deutet auf extreme Angst der
anleger:innen
sobald Sie also zu fallen begannen trat
die Zentralbank an die Öffentlichkeit
und sagte okay wir werden damit aufhören
und zu einem normalen Zinsniveau
zurückkehren
von diesem Moment an Ende 2019 begannen
sie die Zinssätze wieder von 2,5% auf
0,25% zu senken
das kann man in vielen finanzbüchern
nachlesen
das Szenario in dem wir uns heute
befinden mit negativen Zinssätzen ist
völlig und tragbar was auf uns zukommen
mag das ist schwer zu sagen keiner weiß
es wir werden in den sauren Apfel beißen
und es herausfinden müssen die
Zentralbanken haben ohnehin keine andere
Möglichkeit denn das einzige was Sie tun
können ist mehr Geld zu drucken
tatsächlich das einzige was
Zentralbanken tun können ist mehr Geld
zu drucken um all diese Schulden zu
decken sie werden zusammen mit den
Regierungen die Steuern und
Sozialausgaben weiter erhöhen um die
Währung abzuwerten das sind keine bösen
Absichten aber die Zentralbanken sind an
dem Punkt an dem sie mit dem Rücken zur
Wand stehen und gezwungen sind diese
Instrumente zum missbrauchen
[Musik]
sie sind auf der Suche nach Lösungen um
die gesamte Wirtschaft aus dieser
Situation herauszuholen auch wenn diese
nicht unbedingt im Interesse der Bürger
und ihrer persönlichen Freiheit stehen
nicht umsonst heißt die Initiative des
Weltwirtschaftsforums great Reset der
Name der diesen Dokumentarfilm
inspiriert hat
[Musik]
ein Teil ihres Plans ist die Schaffung
digitaler zentralbankwährungen cbdcs
dies würde es den Zentralbanken
ermöglichen ein neues Geldsystem zu
erschaffen dass sie vom aktuellen
abkoppeln können so könnten die Menschen
in dieses neue schuldenfreie System
übergehen und langsam die Schulden aus
dem vorherigen System abbauen ohne ihren
Währungen weiterhin Risiken auszusetzen
die digitale Währung der Zentralbank in
Form an das wird allerdings nicht sofort
geschehen es gibt glaube ich eine zwölf
monatige versuchsperiode bevor sie BDCs
verifiziert und endgültig verwendet
werden
im Moment arbeiten wir an einer
digitalen Lösung
aber wir müssen das ganze Spektrum der
digitalen Zahlungen erfassen das
bedeutet
aber auch cbcd
also alle Themen oder
zahlungsmechanismen die unserer Meinung
nach bereits einen kritischen Punkt
erreicht haben
würden Sie sagen dass die corona-krise
die Notwendigkeit einer digitalen
Zentralbank Währung bzw noch deutlicher
gemacht hat
nun ja ich denke die corona-krise hat
den technischen Wandel und die Nutzung
digitale Innovationen in allen Bereichen
stark beschleunigt
ich meine es ist nicht nur bei
Finanztransaktionen im elektronischen
Handel und im schobesness es gibt so
viele Beispiele dafür ich glaube es
kommt jetzt sehr stark auf die Ideen der
Zentralbanken an
Ende 2020 führte die peoples Bank of
China ein Pilotprogramm in der
chinesischen Stadt zu durch die
BürgerInnen konnten sich auf der
Makroebene eine App herunterladen so
bekommt man ein Gefühl dafür wie das
Geld in der Wirtschaft auf der
Mikroebene fließt das ist natürlich im
westlichen Teil der Welt und denkbar und
stößt ja auch bei vielen Leuten in China
auf Unverständnis
niemand würde den Behörden erlauben
genau zu verfolgen wie sie ihr eigenes
Geld ausgeben wie auch immer sie Geld
ausgeben definieren ob sie nun Wetten
oder ihr Geld weiter investieren der
erste Schritt könnte natürlich das
Ersetzen des physischen Geldes sein
cbdcs müssen zwangsläufig eingeführt
werden die Regierungen werden damit
beginnen Bedürftige Bürger zu
unterstützen indem sie ihnen über eine
direkt von der Zentralbank
kontrollierten Geldbörse Anreize
schaffen
Zentralbanken werden im wesentlichen in
der Lage sein die Geschäftsbanken
auszuschalten die derzeit als
Mittelsmann zwischen Zentralbank und
Bürger fungieren für die Regierungen
wird das viele Dinge vereinfachen wenn
Sie beschließen die Zinssätze zu ändern
können Sie direkt handeln und müssen
nicht mehrere Monate warten bis die
Geschäftsbanken dies in ihrem Systemen
umgesetzt haben sie werden in der Lage
sein die Zinssätze auf der Grundlage des
Profils einer Person oder eines
Unternehmens direkt zu kontrollieren und
Verfallsdaten für Geld festzulegen um
die Menschen so zum Konsum und weg vom
Sparen zu bringen
Bro Paul beschreibt die gut
banks die Zentralbanken wollen den
Menschen direkt Geld zur Verfügung
stellen also direkt im Monetarisierung
aber im Moment können Sie nichts weiter
tun als Geld zu drucken weil das
Bankensystem durch die Geschäftsbanken
gehalten wird eine Möglichkeit wäre ein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen
einzuführen weil dadurch die
Zentralbanken ärmere Menschen direkt
unterstützen könnte
es würde sich nicht in der stattlichen
Bilanz wiederfinden
Zentralbanken denken sie seien
allmächtig und ihre Bilanzen sind
unendlich die moderne Geldtheorie
scheint der vorherrschende Ansatz zu
sein und dies eine Art verrückter
kinesianischer kinesianismus
Zentralbanken können auch die Struktur
des Geldes der Geldpolitik und der
Fiskalpolitik völlig verändern weil sie
es verschiedenen Menschen auf
verschiedene Weise geben können
so können Sie dem Gastronomen einen
Kredit geben aber Sparer der Babyboomer
mit negativen Zinsen bestrafen weil sie
ihr Geld nicht in die Wirtschaft
integrieren wollen so könnten sie
Studenten positive Zinsen geben um Ihnen
beim Sparen zu helfen dies wäre der
Aufstieg der Verhaltensökonomie und von
anreizmodellen
dies ist ein struktureller massiver
Wandel in allem was wir über Wirtschaft
insbesondere Makroökonomie Wissen
niemand ist darauf vorbereitet und
niemand von uns weiß was das bedeutet
ich denke daraus kann sehr viel
Positives entstehen es ist eine elegante
Lösung für einige unserer Probleme aber
diese eleganten Lösungen in Regierungen
und Zentralbanken bringen auch
Einschränkungen mit sich dies ist ein
massiver Wandel in allem was wir über
Wirtschaft insbesondere Makroökonomie
Wissen niemand ist darauf vorbereitet
und niemand von uns weiß was das
bedeutet ich denke daraus kann sehr viel
Positives entstehen es ist eine elegante
Lösung für einige unserer Probleme aber
diese eleganten Lösungen in Regierungen
und Zentralbanken sind auch mit
Nebeneffekten verbunden
das Problem an diesem System ist dass
wir unsere Freiheit aufgeben jede
Transaktion die wir gemacht haben oder
jemals machen werden wird aufgezeichnet
das Bargeld ist Geschichte es gibt keine
Möglichkeit mehr dem Gärtner ein
Trinkgeld in bar zu geben es kann also
auf jeder Ebene besteuert werden wir
bräuchten also kein Finanzamt oder
andere steuererhebungsstellen mehr weil
alles direkt passiert das ist gut aber
auch hier haben wir Freiheit verloren
die das Bargeld uns verschafft haben
Zentralbanken sind ein cbcds
interessiert weil sie dadurch ein
weiteres Kontrollorgan erhalten doch
diese sind keine Erfindung der
Zentralbanken
diese sind wie ich schon sagte keine
Erfindung der Regierungen oder der
Zentralbanken sie sind von anderen
digitalen Währungen abgeleitet wurden
wie zum Beispiel Bitcoin und anderen
altcoins die danach geschaffen wurden
in Wirklichkeit ähneln sie eher ethereum
was Erweiterungen zulässt bzw Updates
ermöglicht mit denen man Funktionen
hinzufügen kann
bitcoin ist aber nur für einen
wertetransfer zu gebrauchen es ist kein
zahlungsnetzwerk
man kann es sich als ein Protokoll von
Transaktionen vorstellen mit dessen
Hilfe ich sehr schnell Geldtransfers
durchführen kann das bitcoin-netzwerk
benötigt lediglich ein paar
Informationen zum Beispiel von wo aus
meine Transaktion an welche Adresse
ausgeführt werden soll sowie die Menge
an Bitcoin die ich transferieren möchte
aus diesen Informationen wird ein
Hashcode erstellt
alle Einträge innerhalb dieser zehn
Minuten werden als Block betrachtet
meiner also Computer die mit dem
Netzwerk verbunden sind können diese
Transaktionen verifizieren meiner sind
also einfach User die bestätigen dass
sich diese Bitcoin habe und diese
transferieren kann somit habe ich
Bitcoin an sie transferiert also
eigentlich sehr einfach
alle diese Computer sind mit dem
Netzwerk verbunden und konkurrieren
darum wer den Block bestätigt denn wer
diesen Block bestätigt und diese
Transaktionen verifiziert wird auf zwei
Arten in Bitcoin belohnt
[Musik]
zum einen gibt es Transaktionskosten
wenn ich Bitcoin versende dann zahle ich
eine bestimmte Gebühr an das Netzwerk
damit dieser Betrag an die meiner
weiterverteilt wird
zum anderen gibt es eine Station von
neuen Bitcoins heute sind es ungefähr
6,25 Bitcoins pro Block wenn ich als
meiner einen Block bestätigen kann
erhalte ich also dafür 6,25 Bitcoin das
klappt natürlich nicht immer da es einen
großen Wettbewerb zwischen den Männern
gibt
also 6,25 Bitcoin pro Block alle 10
Minuten das ist eine ganze Menge
besonders wenn man an den heutigen
Bitcoin Preis denkt
bitcoin ist so aufgebaut dass es ein
Anreizsystem gibt das laut dem Erfinder
von Bitcoin bis zum Jahr 2140 reicht das
heißt dass die Menge der produzierten
Bitcoins alle vier Jahre durch zwei
geteilt wird
als meiner verdiene ich also 6,25
Bitcoin pro Block nach vier Jahren also
der nächsten Halbierung wird es nur noch
halb so viel sein
das ist sozusagen der Anreiz für meiner
ihr Bitcoin meinen Geschäft so effizient
wie möglich zu betreiben und auch ein
Anreiz dafür dass der Preis über einen
bestimmten Niveau bleibt da die meiner
entweder das Geschäft aufgeben wenn der
Preis zu niedrig ist oder beschließen
ihre Bitcoins nicht zu verkaufen weil
sie ihre Betriebskosten nicht decken
können
im bitcoin-protokoll können Änderungen
auf zwei Arten vorgenommen werden eine
davon wird heartfolk genannt hier wird
im Wesentlichen eine Kopie von Bitcoin
erstellt eine Änderung am Protokoll
vorgenommen und diese der Welt
zugänglich gemacht mein Name müssen sich
mit diesem neuen Netzwerk verbinden und
sich dafür entscheiden dieses anstelle
des ursprünglichen Netzwerks zu
verwenden Projekte wie Bitcoin Cash und
bitcoin-vision haben dies getan so
versucht man einzelne Probleme im
bitcoin-netzwerk zu lösen
es gab bereits einen skalierungsansatz
der ist Bitcoin ermöglichen sollte
weiterhin als Währung verwendbar zu sein
er wurde sehr gut genannt wer sich ein
wenig mit kryptowährungen auskennt weiß
was weg macht die Blockgröße sollte von
einem Megabyte auf 2 Megabyte angehoben
werden was doppelt so viele
Transaktionen als bisher im
bitcoin-netzwerk möglich machen würde
zunächst beschlossen dann aber schnell
abgebrochen aus welchen auch immer
somit musste ich erneut nach einem Tool
suchen das Transaktionen in dieser Höhe
tätigen kann denn Bitcoin kann das nicht
nicht mit einem Megabyte Blöcken das ist
schier unmöglich
es gibt eine Menge anderer
kryptowährungen da draußen und wenn Sie
mich fragen welche meiner Meinung nach
am besten geeignet ist in kürzester Zeit
die größte wirtschaftliche Freiheit zu
bringen würde ich Bitcoin Persch ganz
weit vorne platzieren
viele dieser Projekte sind im Vergleich
zu Bitcoin gescheitert und haben stark
an Wert verloren da Leute die in Bitcoin
investiert haben nicht umsteigen wollten
diese Abneigung war vor allem auf einen
Grund zurückzukehren Dezentralisierung
Dezentralisierung bedeutet bei Bitcoin
dass niemand allein das Netzwerk
kontrolliert es ist ein offenes sicheres
Netzwerk das von jedem Teilnehmer
kontrolliert und verbessert wird in
Projekten wie Bitcoin Cash ist die
Anzahl der Teilnehmer viel geringer als
bei Bitcoin was die Sicherheit ver
ringert bitcoinser Toshi Vision ist ein
gutes Beispiel dafür dass im Jahr 2021
Opfer eines 51 prozentigen Angriffs
wurde
die Leistung eines Meiners basiert auf
seiner Rechenleistung diese wird
gewöhnlich als herrsch Rate oder
hasleistung bezeichnet
das mining ist auf verschiedene Knoten
in der ganzen Welt verteilt was bedeutet
dass sie im Optimalfall nicht in den
Händen einer einzigen Einheit liegt
aber was passiert wenn die Hash rate
nicht mehr gut genug verteilt ist was
passiert wenn ein einziges Unternehmen
in der Lage ist mehr als 50% der
hashing-leistung zu erhalten eine
mögliche Folge könnte ein sogenannter
51% Angriff auch bekannt als
mehrheitsangriff sein ein 51% Angriff
ist ein potenzieller Angriff auf ein
blockchain-netzwerk bei dem ein
einzelnes Unternehmen oder eine
organisierte Gruppe in der Lage ist die
Mehrheit der Herr Schrade zu
kontrollieren was zu einer Störung des
Netzwerks führen kann in diesem Szenario
würde der Angreifer über genügend mining
Macht verfügen um Transaktionen
verhindern oder deren Reihenfolge zu
ändern er könnte auch Transaktionen
rückgängig machen die er selbst getätigt
hat was zum double spending Problem
führt ein erfolgreicher Angriff könnte
es dem Angreifer ermöglichen die
Bestätigung einiger oder aller
Transaktionen zu blockieren und so auch
das mining verhindern was zu einem
mining Monopol führen würde
bei einem soft-fock werden Änderungen am
Protokoll vorgenommen die von der
Mehrheit der meiner akzeptiert werden
muss dazu entscheiden die meine einfach
ob sie auf das neue Protokoll umsteigen
und ihre Maschinen aktualisieren wollen
wenn die Mehrheit der meina bei einer
vorher festgelegten blockzahl zustimmt
werden die Änderungen schließlich
offiziell gemacht von diesem Zeitpunkt
an werden die Blöcke auf diese Weise
verifiziert
im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen
Protokollen muss jeder Änderung die am
bitcoin-netzwerk vorgenommen wird
rückwärts kompatibel sein das heißt wenn
jemand Bitcoin besitzt sind seine
Bitcoins auch nach den Änderungen noch
gültig andere Netzwerke sind zwar
einfacher zu ändern aber nicht
abwärtskompatibel sie verlangen oft das
Assets auf Plattformen übertragen werden
die die Änderungen vor einem bestimmten
Datum akzeptieren oder man riskiert
alles zu verlieren
maximum bis zum Jahr 2140 werden maximal
21 Millionen Bitcoin produziert werden
es wird nie mehr geben die Anzahl ist
limitiert
wir können es uns also nicht leisten
Bitcoin zum Beispiel durch ein Update
oder ein Bugfixing zu verlieren eine
funktionierende Implementierung kann
also so einfach nicht funktionieren jede
Änderung muss abwärtskompatibel sein und
das macht es so viel schwieriger etwas
zu ändern
andere Projekte haben ein
Management-Team das entscheidet welche
neue Vision sie haben ihre
Verbesserungen und Updates sind
unabhängig von der Gemeinschaft sie
entscheiden sich einfach für das was sie
glauben am besten für die Gemeinschaft
und deren Interesse ist
das Bitcoin so schwer zu verändern ist
ist einer der Gründe die ihn langfristig
zu einem großartigen Vermögenswert
machen
käufer:innen wissen was sie kaufen und
sie wissen auch dass die Vermögenswerte
stabil bleiben kein anderer
Vermögenswert bietet ein solches Maß an
Sicherheit es wurden zwar auch andere
kryptowährungen erschaffen aber meistens
von Leuten die das Netzwerk weiterhin
kontrollieren und Änderungen vornehmen
um selbst davon zu profitieren ethereum
zum Beispiel die zweitgrößte
kryptowährung nach Markt Kapitalisierung
wird immer noch vom selben Team
kontrolliert dass sie geschaffen hat
diese Leute kontrollieren und werden für
das Netzwerk um erfahrene und nicht
technische Investoren anzulocken die
nicht verstehen was ein Mangel an
Dezentralisierung für die Zukunft der
kryptowährung bedeutet
das Etherium Netzwerk zielt darauf ab
die Funktionsweise des Protokolls zu
ändern diese Änderungen wird es meiner
nur dann ermöglichen zu schürfen wenn
sie zuvor 32 Isa angemeldet haben jeder
kann Bitcoin schürfen aber um ethereum
zu schürfen muss man bald zu den wenigen
Menschen auf der Welt gehören die es
sich leisten können 32 Isa zu kaufen
dadurch wird Etherium zu einer ebenso
guten Währung wie eine Fiat Währung denn
die Entscheidung der wenigen werden sich
auf die Masse auswirken
die gleichen Leute werden sagen dass
Bitcoin hinter anderen kryptowährungen
zurückbleibt sie werden argumentieren
dass Bitcoin zu langsam ist das
Transaktion so teuer sind und dass er
nichts skalierbar ist um als globale
Währung verwendet zu werden
sie werden auch die von Regierungen oder
Mainstream-Medien verwendeten Gründe wie
den Energieverbrauch des
bitcoin-netzwerks nutzen ihr Ziel ist es
den Namen Bitcoin als Werbeträger zu
nutzen um die angeblichen Vorteile ihrer
Projekte hervorzuheben das liegt an
einem Unverständnis daran was mit
Bitcoin gemacht werden kann
stellen sie sich Bitcoin das Asset und
sein Netzwerk als eine Art Grundstruktur
vor die mit mehreren Schichten erweitert
wird diese werden Layer 2 und Layer 3
genannt Leia 2 ist das leining-netzwerk
welches eindeutig das am schnellsten
wachsende ist es handelt sich dabei um
ein anderes Zahlungssystem für dessen
Nutzung ich einen Teil meiner Bitcoins
in das Lightning Network einbringen und
Kanäle öffnen muss
wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Channel bei
ihnen eröffne bedeutet das dass ich
ihnen Geld überweisen kann und habe ich
ihren kanalzugang habe ich außerdem den
Zugang zu jenen Kanälen die sie mit
anderen geöffnet haben wenn wir also
beide das lining-netzwerk Nutzen haben
sie auch Zugang zu allen meinen
Kontakten und diese ebenfalls bezahlen
Zahlungen die ich tätige werden also
durch viele Channels anderer Leute
geleitet
durch diese Struktur kann man
Transaktionen massiv skalieren und das
ermöglicht es Zahlungen tatsächlich
sofort abzuwickeln und das beinahe
kostenlos so etwas gibt es bisher im
Finanzwesen nicht
das Geld würde also nur einmal zwischen
Lightning Netzwerk und Bitcoin
hauptnetzwerk fließen die Transaktion
wird also tatsächlich innerhalb dieses
hauptnetzwerks durchgeführt das erlaubt
es Zahlungen viel schneller und billiger
durchführen zu können aber immer noch
Bitcoin als abwicklungsschicht hat die
diese Transaktionen verifizieren kann
[Musik]
es sind die negativen Umweltauswirkungen
der Server mit der viele dieser
digitalen Währungen überhaupt erst
geschaffen werden
Bitcoin verbraucht mehr Energie als
ganze Länder und es wird prognostiziert
dass er in diesem Jahr so viel Energie
verbrauchen wird wie alle Rechenzentren
auf der ganzen Welt
eine Bitcoin Transaktion ein einziger
Kauf Verkauf oder ein Transfer
verbraucht mehr Strom als ein typischer
us-haushalt in einem Monat
in Moritz
der Hauptbestandteil von Bitcoin wird
als sehr energieaufwendig beschrieben
und es ist eine Tatsache dass das
bitcoin-netzwerk auf seinem Höhepunkt im
Mai 2021 so viel Energie verbrauchte wie
das gesamte Land Schweden
auch wenn das viel zu sein scheint
müssen wir aufschlüsseln woher diese
Energie kommt und wie sich dieser Trend
entwickelt einschließlich der Frage
wohin die großen meiner verlagert werden
um ihre Kosten und Umweltauswirkungen zu
senken
diese Männer sind Unternehmen
die größten unter ihnen sind heute
internationale börsennotierte
Unternehmen die zur Gründung eines
mining-unternehmens den Kauf von
Hardware benötigen
es werden Immobilien und Computer
benötigt um das bitcoin-netzwerk
anzuzapfen dass Meiningen zu beginnen
und diese Rechenmaschinen zu lagern die
Preise für Hardware oder Immobilien sind
weltweit vergleichbar natürlich können
bessere Angebote ausgehandelt werden
diese Kosten der Versorgungskette sind
jedoch nicht ausschlaggebend für meiner
um einen Vorteil gegenüber der
Konkurrenz zu haben
ausschlaggebend ist ja allein der Faktor
Energie
der dritte Faktor und das ist der
wichtigste ist die Energie die meiner
aufwenden müssen um Ihre Hardware zu
betreiben
die Preise variieren von Land zu Land
oder Region zu Region sie variieren
außerdem je nach der gewählten
Energiequelle in der Region die
billigste Quelle sind derzeit immer die
erneuerbaren Energien oder die
Kernenergie doch Kernenergie wird von
den Regierungen zur Zeit ausgebremst
diese
Unternehmen müssen sich also
zwangsläufig selbst um die Entwicklung
von erneuerbaren Energien kümmern und
diese vorantreiben um langfristig
billiger zu werden
gewonnen werden aus grüne Energie und
aus verschwendete Energie die von uns
produzierte Energie ist immer im
Überschuss vorhanden wir verbrauchen nie
hundert Prozent der von den Kraftwerken
erzeugten Energie weil sonst die Gefahr
von Stromausfällen besteht
in den USA gehen schätzungsweise fünf
bis sechs Prozent der erzeugten Energie
auf dem Transportweg verloren
das sind etwa 211 Stunden
diese Menge allein ist fast doppelt so
hoch wie der Bitcoin verbraucht zum
Zeitpunkt seines Allzeithochs
heutzutage drängen die Regierungen auf
die Einführung von solar- und
Windenergie und beschließen gegen die
Atomkraft vorzugehen obwohl dies auf dem
Papier positiv klingt hat es leider auch
negative Auswirkungen mit unseren
heutigen Technologien lässt sich die
erzeugte Energie nicht speichern
daher kann die Energie aus sonnen und
Windenergie nur dann erzeugt werden wenn
es sonnig oder windig ist das macht sie
sehr unzuverlässig und erfordert das
täglich Reservekraftwerke vorhanden und
aktiv sind und diesen Mangel an Energie
auszugleichen
dieser negative Effekt für dazu dass
Deutschland der größte Anwender von
Solar und Wind Energie in Europa heute
wieder die gleiche Menge an CO2
produziert wie vor 20 Jahren die grüne
Politik auf der ganzen Welt hat die
Einführung von Kernkraftwerken
verhindert und die Welt indirekt dazu
gezwungen mehr Erdgas zu verbrauchen
Erdgas hat wie andere Energieträger auch
ganz eigene Probleme es wird mehr Erdgas
gefördert als verbraucht wird was zum
sogenannten abfackeln führt
das Abfackeln ist einfach das
überschüssige Gas das gefördert wird und
verbrannt werden muss es ist ein
Standard und eine notwendige Gewohnheit
in der Industrie
[Musik]
es wird geschätzt dass allein im Jahr
2019 weltweit 150 Milliarden Kubikmeter
Erdgas abgefackelt wurden das ist die
gleiche Menge die Japan und Korea im
selben Jahr importiert haben und die
sich in der Luft verflüchtigt und etwa
300 Millionen Tonnen CO2 erzeugt hat
[Musik]
was dem gesamten jährlichen Emissionen
Italiens entspricht
um ihre Kosten und ihren
Energieverbrauch zu senken schließen
sich die meiner direkt an diese
Energiequellen an die bisher
unzugänglich waren
da Bitcoin meiner überall auf der Welt
agieren können ohne dass sie sich in der
Nähe von Gemeinden befinden müssen
Zapfen Sie diese Energie bereits direkt
an da sie mit den Erzeugern attraktive
Preise für Energie aushandeln können die
anderenfalls abgefackelt würde oder
durch den Transport verlorengänge
sie haben auch Zugang zu weiter
entfernten natürlichen Energiequellen
die von den Gemeinden nicht genutzt
werden können dies gilt für
Wasserkraftwerke geothermische Energie
und sogar ganz neue Ideen wie die
Energiegewinnung aus Vulkanen
je mehr Zeit vergeht und je mehr diese
Unternehmen wachsen desto
wahrscheinlicher wird es dass sie auf
diese Energiequellen umsteigen um ihre
Gewinne zu steigern
andere Unternehmen arbeiten aktiv an
Innovationen zu Energieerzeugung um
meiner mit sauberer und billiger Energie
zu versorgen die langfristigen positiven
Auswirkungen die die Einführung von
Bitcoin auf unserer Energieerzeugung
haben könnte werden weitgehend
unterschätzt und sogar von Regierungen
und anderen Mainstream-Medien ignoriert
das Argument des Energieverbrauchs ist
somit unglücklich platziert wenn man den
gesamten Energieverbrauch der Welt im
Kontext sieht gerade wenn man ihn mit
dem Energieverbrauch der traditionellen
finanzdienstleistungsbanken vergleicht
diese verbrauchen viel mehr Energie da
jede von ihnen natürlich aufgrund von
Datenschutz und Sicherheitsvorgaben ihre
eigene abwicklungsinfrastruktur schaffen
muss
Bitcoin hingegen besitzt eine
clusterfunktion alles geschieht im
Rahmen dieses dezentralisierten Systems
man muss also ein bisschen Energie
einsetzen bekommt aber im Gegenzug
riesige finanzielle Freiheit
[Musik]
Bitcoin wurde von einer Person oder
einer Gruppe von Personen unter dem
Synonym satochinacamoto geschaffen sie
schrieben das Whitepaper bauten das
Netzwerk auf veröffentlichten es und
tauschten sich in vielen Foren aus bevor
sie eines Tages verschwanden
ein genialer Unbekannter hat
Technologien und
verschlüsselungsprotokolle auf eine neue
Art und Weise kombiniert die ultimative
Währung geschaffen und dann den
nobelsten und wichtigsten Schritt von
allen getan er verschwand
[Musik]
nachdem er das alles geschaffen hatte
sprach er öffentlich in Foren darüber
förderte die Idee diskutierte sie und
nahm Verbesserungen vor das ist das
ursprüngliche mindset der meiner ab dem
Zeitpunkt als die Gemeinschaft begann
sich der Sache anzunehmen
verschwandoto er antwortete nicht mehr
in den Foren und zeigte keinerlei
Lebenszeichen
er hat nie die Bitcoin angerührt die
seit der Erschaffung in seinem Wallet
liegen diese befinden sich immer noch
auf den ursprünglichen wallet-adressen
er überließ sie vollständig der
Gemeinschaft Sinn der Sache war es die
Kontrolle über unser derzeitiges Finanz
und Geldsystem loszuwerden und es den
Menschen zur Verfügung zu stellen
deswegen heißt es Bitcoin wurde von
Menschen für Menschen geschaffen es soll
von einer Gemeinschaft und nicht von
einer zentralen Behörde kontrolliert
werden
jeder kann sich an der Verbesserung des
Netzwerks beteiligen sei es durch
Übersetzungen
oder durch die Entwicklung von
Anwendungen die Bitcoins zusätzliche
Funktionen verleihen aber nur das
Bitcoin Kernteam kann tatsächlich
Änderungen am bitcoin-netzwerk vornehmen
ich denke ein großer Teil der Verwaltung
im Bitcoin Ökosystem besteht aus Bitcoin
kernentwickler:innen
ich hatte das Glück und die Ehre mit
vielen von ihnen zu sprechen
wissen Sie einen großen Teil dieses
Ökosystems verstand ich noch nicht es
war eine steile Lernkurve auf der
technologie-seite
aber als ich mich mit ihnen über
Wirtschaft Wirtschaftstheorie und
gescheiterte Währungssysteme unterhielt
merkte ich bald dass sie sich in
Wirtschaftsgeschichte sehr gut auskennen
es gibt mir ein hohes Maß an Vertrauen
sie sind wirklich in einer noblen
Mission unterwegs
sie könnten viel mehr Geld bei Google
Facebook oder in anderen technologischen
Bereichen verdienen
aber sie haben sich für dieses edle Ziel
entschieden und haben diesen unglaublich
starken technischen Background
The Prodigy backgrounds so sie verfügen
über ein gutes ökonomisches Verständnis
insbesondere der Geldsysteme
und das beruhigt mich doch sehr wenn ich
über die Steuerung des Ökosystems
nachdenke viel viel mehr als wir es in
anderen finanzökosystem finden würden
Gold stand schon immer für den auch noch
heutzutage verwendeten Ausdruck hartes
Geld das Wort Hartgeld beruht auf der
Tatsache dass Gold physisch also hart
ist ebenso wie der Ausdruck stabiles
Geld Goldmünzen hatten einen
unvergleichlichen Klang und wurden
deshalb immer als das härteste Geld
angesehen
Bitcoin folgt denselben
Gesetzmäßigkeiten aber das Protokoll
wird streng befolgt was es zu einer Art
besseren Gold macht Gold wurde von den
Regierungen streng kontrolliert wie ich
anfangs bereits erwähnt habe als es um
die Abschaffung des Goldstandards ging
war es den Menschen in Großbritannien
während des Zweiten Weltkriegs nicht
erlaubt persönlich Gold zu halten
genauso in den USA der 70er Jahre man
musste sein Gold der Regierung verkaufen
da die Regierung ihre Reserven erhöhen
wollte
das ist in der Vergangenheit schon öfter
vorgekommen wenn zum Beispiel Krisen
abzusehen waren auch heute noch
schließen Sie in Polen wenn sie Gold
kaufen möchten der Regierung ihre
persönlichen Daten mitteilen und angeben
wie viel Gold sie besitzen
somit weist die Regierung wohin sie
gehen muss wenn Sie Ihre Goldreserven
erhöhen will
[Musik]
in den letzten sieben Jahren kam es
durchschnittlich jedes Jahr zu einer
internationalen Währungskrise wer
profitiert von solchen Krisen kein
Arbeiter kein Kapitalanleger und auch
nicht die Produzenten von
Vermögenswerten Gewinner sind die
internationalen geldspekulanten sie
leben von den Krisen und helfen so dabei
Krisen zu schaffen in den letzten Wochen
haben die Spekulanten einen Krieg gegen
den amerikanischen Dollar entfacht
die Stärke der Währung einer Nation
beruht auf der Stärke ihrer Wirtschaft
und die amerikanische Wirtschaft ist die
bei weitem stärkste der ganzen Welt
dementsprechend habe ich den
Finanzminister beauftragt die zur
Verteidigung des Dollar gegen
Spekulanten erforderlichen Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen ich habe Finanzminister
Connelly angewiesen vorübergehend die
Konvertibilität des Dollar in Gold oder
andere Reservemittel auszusetzen
ausgenommen sind Beträge oder
Bedingungen die als im Interesse der
Währungsstabilität und als Interesse der
Vereinigten Staaten liegend angesehen
werden
in brettenwutz wurde eine Vereinbarung
getroffen wonach ab 1945 und dem Ende
des Krieges alle Währungen in den Dollar
und der Dollar in Gold konvertierbar
sein sollten
damals waren die Goldreserven der letzte
Mechanismus zum Ausgleich von
zahlungsbilanzdefiziten
Wutz kam diesem Prozess jedoch zuvor in
dem es zuließ dass die einzige Währung
als offizielle Währung für ausländische
Zentralbanken betrachtet wurde
diese konnten darauf Ihre gesamten
Defizite in Dollar und nicht in Gold
begleichen
das ist der grundlegende Unterschied
zwischen dem klassischen Goldstandard
und dem sogenannten goldtausch Standard
der in brettenwutz gesetzlich verankert
wurde und bei dem 1971 sowohl
Großbritannien als auch einige andere
Länder beschlossen ihre riesigen Dollar
Reserven einzulösen
wollte sie natürlich auf seine Art alle
toppen
Burg
[Musik]
diese Länder hat nun das Recht Gold so
Einlösung ihrer Dollar Reserven zu
verlangen dies könnte die Vereinigten
Staaten in eine Situation der
Zahlungsunfähigkeit bringen
[Musik]
die 60er Jahre waren geprägt von
Finanzkrisen die den Dollar betrafen
aber der totale Zusammenbruch kam am 15
August 1971
Nixon sagte es tut mir leid wir können
unsere Schulden nicht zahlen und wir
werden sie ganz sicher nicht in Gold
begleichen
unseren Freunden im Ausland
einschließlich der vielen
verantwortungsbewussten Mitglieder der
internationalen bankengemeinschaft die
sich für Stabilität und Fernhandel
einsetzen versichere ich die Vereinigten
Staaten waren schon immer ein
vorausschauender und vertrauenswürdiger
Handelspartner und werden es auch
weiterhin sein gemeinsam mit dem
Internationalen Währungsfond und
denjenigen die mit uns handelt treiben
werden wir uns für die notwendigen
Reformen einsetzen eindringend
benötigtes neues internationales
Währungssystem zu schaffen
[Musik]
bis zum heutigen Tag kann Gold nur an
Wochentagen an den Märkten gehandelt
werden weil einige wenige Leute dies so
beschlossen haben bei Bitcoin kann
niemand solche Entscheidungen treffen
einzelne Börsen können das aber sie
würden gegen ihre Konkurrenz verlieren
die Regierungen haben keine Möglichkeit
herauszufinden ob die Menschen Bitcoins
besitzen bitcoin ist die sicherste Art
Vermögen zu halten die im Internet
beheimatet ist daher ist es immer und
überall verfügbar noch nie in der
Geschichte war es so einfach Vermögen zu
erwerben jeder der über einen
Internetanschluss verfügt kann sich
anonym in das Netz einklinken und auf
dieselbe Weise auf sein Vermögen
zugreifen unabhängig von seinem
geographischen Standort und ebenfalls
anonym
dies ist für Regierungen beängstigend
sie wissen dass wenn die Menschen sich
von fiatwährungen abwenden neue Schulden
die zu Erzeugung von Inflation und zur
Entwertung von Währung notwendig sind
nicht mehr nach dem gleichen Regeln
geschaffen werden dies gefährdet ihren
gesamten Status Quo und den ihrer Eliten
davor haben sie Angst und versuchen
deshalb das Projekt zu verhindern
tatsächlich hat China gerade in diesem
Jahr jegliches Bitcoin mining und jede
Art von Austausch untersagt was wenn man
als totalitäre Regierung denkt eine
großartige Strategie ist wenn man
allerdings an die Freiheit der Menschen
denkt ist es das nicht und China sind
nicht die einzigen
auch das Vereinigte Königreich hat hart
durchgegriffen sie haben Bitcoin Werbung
auf Bussen oder in der U-Bahn verboten
Anzeigen die für Bitcoin wären wurden
von der Regierung sofort verboten sie
haben auch Druck auf die Geschäftsbanken
ausgeübt um Überweisungen von britischen
Bankkonten an kryptobörsen zu blockieren
damit sie das britische Pfund nicht
verlassen und stattdessen Bitcoin kaufen
können
sie haben also nicht nur Angst sondern
ergreifen auch Maßnahmen um später ihre
eigenen digitalen zentralbankwährungen
einzuführen wenn sie keinen Bitcoin
haben bieten Sie ihnen diese Alternative
sie würden sich natürlich für diese
Alternative entscheiden da sie dann
keine andere Wahl haben
der Grund warum sie Bitcoin verbieten
wollen ist dass sie die Macht kennen die
Bitcoin hat und sie wissen dass es den
Regierungen diese Macht nehmen würde
solange Regierungen das Geld
kontrollieren können Sie Entscheidungen
treffen mit denen die Bürger nicht
einverstanden sind oder von denen sie
nicht wissen dass Sie direkte oder
indirekte Auswirkungen auf sie haben
werden solange Regierungen das Geld
kontrollieren können Sie Ihr
Gewaltmonopol aufrechterhalten Bitcoin
wurde vor 12 Jahren nach der globalen
Finanzkrise als Lösung für die
finanziellen Probleme unserer Wirtschaft
und zu vollständigen Beseitigung des
Missbrauchs den Menschen mit unserem
Geldsystem treiben können geschaffen
[Musik]
hierzu es ist wichtig zu verstehen dass
das fiatssystem kein sorgfältig bewusst
oder absichtlich entworfenes
finanzbetriebssystem wie Bitcoin war
viel mehr hat es sich in einem komplexen
Prozess des Kompromisses zwischen
politischen Zwängen und Erfahrungen
entwickelt
bitcoin ist ein echter Vermögenswert und
er wird bleiben
und seine Höchstgrenze von 21 Millionen
macht ihn zum knappsten Vermögenswert
der Welt und letztlich zum attraktivsten
Vermögenswert viele Finanzmanager sehen
das ebenso
sollten wir recht haben und die
Unternehmen weiterhin ihre barmitte in
etwas wie Bitcoin umschichten und die
Institutionen die Großinvestoren
beginnen 5% ihrer Gelder zu investieren
dann glauben wir dass der Preis das
Zehnfache des heutigen Standes erreichen
wird
the price also statt 45.000 über 500.000
Bitcoin bietet einige Vorteile und
sollte im Portfolio eines jeden Anlegers
enthalten sein
das Wichtigste ist sich langfristig
abzusichern ich persönlich denke das
Bitcoin ein langfristiger wertschutz ist
ich halte einen gewissen Geldbetrag in
Bitcoin es ist nur ein kleiner Einsatz
von dem was ich in Gold und ein noch
kleinerer Prozentsatz von dem was ich in
anderen Anlageklassen habe ich denke das
hat seine Berechtigung
ich mag Bitcoin als Portfolio
diversifizieren ich werde immer gefragt
wie man sein Portfolio gestalten soll
ich sage immer das einzige was ich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt sagen kann ist ich
habe 5% in Gold 5% in Bitcoin 5% in
Bargeld und 5% in Rohstoffen ich weiß
nicht was ich mit meinen anderen 80%
machen soll
ich besitze Bitcoin und seit ich es
gekauft habe ist es stark gestiegen
offensichtlich ändert sich der Einfluss
dieser Anlageklasse
ich denke es lohnt sich alle
Alternativen zu Bargeld und zu einigen
anderen Finanzanlagen in Betracht zu
ziehen
bitcoin ist glaube ich eine weitere
Alternative
wir hatten 26% mehr Dollar im Umlauf uns
in den letzten 244 Jahren wenn man den
gesamten Stimulus in die Rechnung mit
einbezieht sind das weitere 16 Prozent
wenn wir also einen Anstieg des Dollar
Volumens um 40% hatten wird sich das in
den Vermögenswerten niederschlagen
ich begann meine berufliche Laufbahn in
den 80er Jahren der Peso stand bei 20:1
heute sind wir bei 20.000 zu 1 zumindest
hier in Mexiko
wenn wir nach Venezuela Argentinien oder
Simbabwe schauen stehen diese Zahlen in
keinem Verhältnis zueinander das
fiat-system ist ein großer Betrug und
wir sehen das jetzt auch in den
Vereinigten Staaten
von Bargeld reicht bis zum Mond die
Ausgabe des Donners als harte Währung
ist ein Scherz
wenn sich die Fakten ändern ändere ich
meine Strategie ich bin ein Investor das
Umfeld verändert sich rasant und die
regul Behörden in der Schweiz haben mich
wirklich zum Umdenken veranlasst schauen
wir uns Frankreich Deutschland oder
England an Kanada öffnet sich gerade und
hat jetzt sieben verschiedene Assets mit
kryptowährungen als Basiswert die an
ihren Börsen gehandelt werden das kommt
einer ein 180 Grad Wende gleich
wenn man versteht was bitcoin ist
versteht man auch warum Unternehmen wie
morgens Stanley in den Markt einsteigen
es handelt sich um einen begrenzten
Vermögenswert die große Differenz
zwischen Angebot und Nachfrage sowie die
Berechenbarkeit der blockschein machen
dieses asset sehr attraktiv in einer
Welt in der gnadenlos Geld gedruckt wird
es ist eine erstaunliche Leistung ist
von der Programmierung bis hierher zu
schaffen wo wir jetzt stehen es hat die
ganze Zeit standgehalten
ich finde sie haben 13 Jahre lang ein
unglaublich gutes Marketing betrieben
gerade junge Leute schauen auf Bitcoin
wie ich damals auf Gold
ich mag Bitcoin bitcoin ist pure
Mathematik und Mathematik gibt es schon
seit tausenden von Jahren zwei plus zwei
ist gleich 4 das wird auch in den
nächsten 2000 Jahren so sein ich mag
also die Idee in etwas zu investieren
das zuverlässig beständig ehrlich und zu
100 Prozent zuverlässig ist
ich denke seine Limitierung auf nur 21
Millionen bitcoin ist der Schlüssel zum
Problem
solange man nicht über die Anzahl
hinausgeht kann sein Vermögenswert nicht
verringert werden
[Musik]
weil ich damit in die Zukunft des
Sicherheit investieren kann
es gibt einige Länder oder auch Regionen
wie zum Beispiel in der Schweiz wo man
seine Steuern in Bitcoin bezahlen kann
eine wachsende Annahme und Akzeptanz ist
jetzt überall auf der Welt spürbar
Regeln werden geändert um es zu festigen
Community die Gemeinschaft macht es
lebendig und unabhängig von politischen
oder geopolitischen Situationen die
Tatsache dass die Regierungen selbst die
Nutzung dieser Technologie in jeglicher
Form zulässt bestätigt dies
mein Name ist Nagy bukille ich bin
Präsident von El Salvador
große Ideen sind etwas wundervolles und
haben eine große Bedeutung aber wie die
meisten schönen Dinge können Sie genauso
vergänglich sein wie unsere Weisheit als
ich ein Kind war dachten wir sehr oft
über die Zukunft nach wir waren
begeistert und konnten es kaum erwarten
an ihrer Entstehung teilzuhaben aber
fast jeder denkt bei unserer Zukunft an
Atomkrieg am Klimakatastrophen an Hunger
und an Elend wir sehen nicht die vielen
neuen und wunderbaren Dinge die
erschaffen wurden die Menschheit kann
alles schaffen es ist unser
Einfallsreichtum der uns von anderen
Arten unterscheidet
wollen wir diese Ideen zur Gestaltung
unserer Zukunft einbringen wenn wir uns
nach den bedeutendsten Innovationen der
Geschichte umschauen glaube ich das
Bitcoin eine davon ist deshalb werde ich
nächste Woche einen Gesetzesentwurf in
den Kongress Einbringen der Bitcoin zu
einem gesetzlichen Zahlungsmittel in El
Salvador macht dies wird Arbeitsplätze
schaffen und dazu beitragen dass
tausende Menschen zusätzlich in die
Wirtschaft integriert werden
[Musik]
die Gesetzgeber in El Salvador brachen
in Applaus aus nachdem sie am Mittwoch
für die Zulassung von Bitcoin als
gesetzliches Zahlungsmittel gestimmt
hatten damit ist das
zentralamerikanische Land das erste der
Welt dass die kryptowährung vollständig
einführt
[Musik]
die Zeit ist gekommen
wir sind bereit
ist das
ist ein wichtiger Schritt für unser Land
für unsere Technologie unsere Zukunft
der uns finanzielle Chancen
Investitionen Tourismus Innovationen und
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung bringt
weitere ehrgeizige Pläne für Bitcoin
demnach die Energie aus Vulkanen des
Landes für das Bitcoin mining nutzen zu
wollen
er beauftragte des staatliche
geothermie-unternehmen mit der
Ausarbeitung eines entsprechenden Plans
das Ziel soll es wohl sein die
Verwendung von Bitcoin als
Zahlungsmittel als Tauschmittel
reibungsloser zu machen alle Steuern auf
Kapitalgewinne abzuschaffen die
natürlich ein großes Hindernis für den
wirklichen Einsatz als Währung sind um
beispielsweise Bitcoin basierte
Überweisungen billiger zu machen das
scheint also die hauptstoßrichtung
dieses Gesetzes zu sein
welche Schlüsse können wir daraus für
die Zukunft auch über El Salvador
hinausziehen glauben Sie dass sich
andere anerkannte Länder wie El Salvador
und andere größere Länder anschließen
werden
wir wissen dass die Bitcoin
kryptowährung stable coins in Ländern
wie Kolumbien und Argentinien eine sehr
hohe Marktdurchdringung hat in
Lateinamerika sind Staatspleiten oder
Phasen hoher Inflation oder monetärer
Repression keine Seltenheit daher sehen
wir dort eine hohe Marktdurchdringung es
gibt sicherlich einige politische
Entscheidungsträger die eine Möglichkeit
darin sehen sich beliebt zu machen indem
sie ihre Affinität dazu signalisieren
nun wir werden sehen was passiert aber
das ist das erste Mal El Salvador ist
der erste Staat der nicht zu den Pariser
Staaten gehört der die bitcoin-nutzung
legitimiert und legalisiert hat so wie
es geplant war
Banken sind Unternehmen und anders als
Regierungen haben sie natürlich ihre
eigenen Interessen und werden sich immer
an die Bedürfnisse ihrer Kunden anpassen
sie erkennen dass sie neue
Finanzdienstleistungen rund um
kryptowährungen anbieten müssen um nicht
ins Hintertreffen zu geraten
wir werden die alten Dienstleistungen
einfach nicht mehr benötigen weil all
dies bereits in einer völlig
dezentralisierten und unkontrollierten
Form existiert
und den Verkauf der digitalen Währung
über Ihre bestehenden Konten schon in
diesem Jahr zu ermöglichen für weitere
Details schalten wir zu unserem
Bankexperten usun was musste hinter den
Kulissen passieren damit die Menschen in
ihren Banken Zugang zu Bitcoin haben
hi Kelly schön hier zu sein so viel ich
weiß gibt es da einige Firmen wie zum
Beispiel FIS einen backend-anbieter für
Banken der über tausende von Girokonten
mit etwa 300 Millionen Dollar wacht also
ein reiner Technologieanbieter der eine
Reihe von Banken unterstützt
ein weiteres Bitcoin war Unternehmen ist
neidig
das Unternehmen kann dann durchaus mit
Galaxy Investment vergleichen nein die
cut Vereinbarungen mit morgens den nie
getroffen um institutionelle Fond für
ihre Kunden anzubieten also bereits
einige aufstrebende Akteure die sich mit
einigen etablierten Technologie
Anbietern zusammentun FIS ist ein
Unternehmen mit einer
Marktkapitalisierung von 95 Milliarden
Dollar ihre Mission ist es Ihren Kunden
sehr einfach einen Zugang zu Bitcoin zu
ermöglichen
letztlich handelt es sich um einen
finanziellen Vermögenswert es wurden
Studien durchgeführt die besagen dass
wenn die Menschen die Möglichkeit haben
Bitcoin über Ihre bestehenden Konten
oder über ein Internetportal zu
verwalten steigt auch ihre Akzeptanz
gegenüber Bitcoin
und darauf wird es in Auslaufen Kunden
werden in Zukunft die Möglichkeit haben
über ihre Banken also durch eine Bank
App oder ähnliches Krypto zu handeln
genauso wie sie es bisher mit Aktien
oder Geld tun
nun wir wollen natürlich bei jeder
Weiterentwicklung dabei sein aber wir
entscheiden nicht was sich durchsetzt
oder nicht wir Kühen keine Gewinner oder
Verlierer wir bereiten uns einfach
darauf vor was möglicherweise passieren
könnte ich denke kryptowährungen sind
entspannender Trend bitcoin ist in
meinen Augen eine Art digitales Gold und
wir versuchen natürlich die
Verwendbarkeit rund um Bitcoin zu
verbessern so sollte es auch möglich
sein Bitcoin mit seiner Visa Karte zu
bezahlen
und wenn jemand mit Bitcoin einkaufen
möchte verwendet er natürlich ebenfalls
seine Kreditkarte um bei 70 Millionen
Händlern auf der ganzen Welt einzukaufen
das versuchen wir zu erreichen wir
arbeiten mit den 35 größten digitalen
Vermögenswerten den größten Krypto wurde
jetzt auf der ganzen Welt zusammen wir
stellen sicher dass die verschiedenen
digitalen Währungen in eine viertwährung
umgewandelt werden können und das Geld
dann per Visa in einer Rolle beim
Händler auftaucht
wir befinden uns an einem Punkt an dem
die Märkte ein Allzeithoch erreicht
haben alle Zahlen zeigen dass wir uns
auf dem Höhepunkt unseres Zyklus
befinden wir haben Unternehmen die jetzt
schon scheitern angefangen in China
wir sitzen auf einem riesigen Berg von
Geld das natürlich nicht in den Taschen
der Arbeiter existiert aber in den
Systemen der Banken dieses Geld muss
unser Finanzsystem auch wieder verlassen
denn dieses Geld verliert sehr schnell
an Wert und es gibt Wertverluste also
müssen Investoren ihr Geld loswerden
wenn sie keine Wertverluste riskieren
wollen sie wollen Gewinne erzielen und
keine Verluste
sie werden also ihr Geld aus den
Finanzmärkten abziehen was zur natürlich
zu einem noch stärkeren Rückgang führen
wird das ist nicht ungewöhnlich und und
in jedem Zyklus vor die meisten Anleger
investieren dann allerdings in
Staatsanleihen da deren Zinsen von den
Regierungen gezahlt werden die Zinsen
richten sich nach den Zinssätzen die von
der Zentralbank festgelegt werden
das bedeutet wenn ich heutzutage als
Anleger eine Rendite von einem Prozent
pro Jahr haben möchte und ich eine
europäische Anleihe kaufe werde ich
diese ein Prozent nicht bekommen da
gerade ein Negativzins herrscht
damit kostet mich diese Anleihe sogar
Geld anstatt dass sie mir Rendite
einbringt diese Tatsache führt natürlich
zu einem Szenario in dem die Investoren
auch hier ihr Geld abziehen da
Staatsanleihen nicht länger Gewinn
versprechend sind
aber wohin fließt dann das ganze Geld
richtig es fließt in Gold aber Gold wie
wir gerade gesehen haben wird von den
Regierungen kontrolliert und da ist von
den Regierungen kontrolliert wird ist
der Preis in den letzten zehn Jahren
nicht wirklich gestiegen
wir können also davon ausgehen dass ein
großer Teil des Geldes in Gold fließen
wird weil es eine Art Sicherheit
darstellt
aber gleichzeitig entsteht ein ganz
neuer Finanzmarkt der neben den ganzen
anderen kryptowährungen von Bitcoin
angeführt wird mit Bitcoin kann das
erste Mal in der Geschichte des
Finanzwesens ein Vermögenswert so
schnell zu so einer hohen Bewertung
hinzu kommt dass seine Technologie
weltweit am schnellsten angenommen wurde
zuvor war es das Internet das so
revolutionär war noch nie haben wir
erlebt dass sich etwas so schnell
durchgesetzt hat was den technologischen
Fortschritt angeht im Moment
beschleunigt sich die Welt von Bitcoin
und kryptowährungen schneller als das
Internet da es gleichzeitig eine sehr
große Gruppe von Menschen anspricht
vor allem jüngere Generationen die sich
nicht in Machtpositionen befinden
somit boomt der kryptomarkt ich möchte
Bitcoin hier noch einmal hervorheben
weil er der sicherste Vermögenswert ist
alle anderen kryptowährungen gehen den
gleichen Weg des bitcoin-netzwerkes
investieren wollen ist der Kauf von
Bitcoin wohl ihre beste Chance ihr
Portfolio abzusichern
beim bitcoin ist
seine Volatilität stellt für sie eher
ein geringeres Risiko gegenüber den
traditionellen Vermögenswerten da
deshalb denke ich und ich bin nicht der
einzige der so denkt dass Bitcoin das
schwarze Loch sein wird das einen großen
Teil des Geldes verschlucken wird das
aus den traditionellen Märkten fließt
weil es dort einfach keinen Wert mehr
hat
because will
Justin ein solches Vermögen das unseren
technologischen Fortschritt mit unseren
Finanzsystemen verbindet hat es bisher
noch nicht gegeben es ist an der Zeit
dass die Menschen eine Währung haben die
so offen und anonym ist wie das Internet
mit Bitcoin wird den Regierungen die
Kontrolle über das Geld entzogen und dem
Volk zurückgegeben
dies entzieht den Regierungen die
unzählige Probleme mit Korruption
Machtmissbrauch oder der Einschränkung
unserer Freiheit haben enorme Macht wir
haben gesehen dass unser Finanzsystem
einen Reset braucht und die einzige
Lösung die die Regierungen haben ist
weitere Billionen zu drucken dabei
entwerten Sie unsere Währung auf dem Weg
dorthin werden sie die Menschen immer
abhängiger von den Regierungen machen
weil die Sozialausgaben steigen müssen
um ihre unverantwortliche Geldverwaltung
zu decken dies verschafft den
Regierungen eine
schneeball-effektschleife aus Inflation
was zu einer ärmeren Bevölkerung führt
was wiederum zu mehr Sozialausgaben
führt was wiederum zu mehr staatlicher
Kontrolle führt
bitcoin ist der Ausweg aus diesem
Kontrollsystem das nur die Reichen und
die Elite begünstigt diese Leute haben
kein Interesse daran dass Bitcoin als
Währung erfolgreich sein wird da das
Volk Bitcoin kontrolliert und dadurch
ihren Reichtum zuerst vergrößert bevor
Leute die sich selbst als die Elite
betrachten eine Chance dazu haben
Bitcoin erobert langsam die Welt und
wird einen großen Teil des Geldes
absorbieren das derzeit in unseren alten
Finanzsystemen steckt wird das
fiatssystem bald Geschichte sein
[Musik]